the biden administration finally
admitting the president flat out lied
when he accused border patrol agents of
whipping migrants the head of the border
patrol announcing the results of a
months-long investigation into the
incident where democrats and the media
claimed that agents were striking
illegal border crossers
after an extensive review
the u.s attorney
issued their decision
not to prosecute the case opr found no
evidence border patrol agents involved
in this
incident struck any person with their
reins intentionally or
otherwise the false claims that the
border agents were whipping migrants was
quickly debunked but remember that
didn't stop the biden administrations
from smearing the border patrol on
horseback who were just doing their job
to see people treat it like they did
horses barely running them over people
being strapped it's outrageous i promise
you those people will pay and as we all
know it also evoked images of some of
the worst moments of our history
where that kind of behavior has been
used against
the indigenous people of our country has
been used against african americans
during times of slavery saw horrifying
images that do not reflect who we are
who we aspire to be or the integrity and
values of our truly heroic personnel in
the department of homeland security the
horrific video of the cbp officers on
horse on horses using brutal and
inappropriate measures against innocent
people
the four agents aren't out of the woods
just yet they're being referred for
punishment for using offensive language
an unnecessary force the agents could be
suspended for up to 14 days
unfortunately border patrol not the only
ones being attacked by the biden
administration the white house accusing
texas governor greg abbott of causing
chaos over his moves to send illegal
immigrants back to where they came from
i'll say this the immigration
enforcement is a federal authority
and states should not be mandating it
meddling in it that is just especially
uh governor
texas governor of abbott who has a track
record of causing chaos and confusion at
the border but again this is an
immigration enforcement enforcement is a
federal authority
jessica i'm going to start with you
the fact is that the president didn't
just lie here but you had the most
powerful man in the country the most
powerful woman in the country the vice
president yet maxine waters and the rest
of them
you've got them
pre-judging a situation creating a false
narrative by these powerful people and
they were just wrong i mean should they
be in these positions making these
judgments given the fact that they
didn't even know what the facts were at
that time well i'm certainly not willing
to say that joe biden shouldn't be
president because he got this wrong or
the kamala harris
it's real simple this one he should
backtrack and he should say that he was
wrong and they have a 511 page report
that they can refer to and they did find
that there were failures at quote
multiple levels of the agency lack of
training dangerous behavior etc that's
something that cpb has to deal with
but when you publicly demonize someone
or an organization or an institution it
does damage to morale within that
institution obviously and to those that
support them and this was something that
even
democrats who are representing
constituencies along the border were
saying that you know this is actually
how it's supposed to be i'm not someone
that typically
rides a horse and i did not know that
that's uh what was supposed to be going
on and you should just eat crow on this
particular one and say we were wrong
about this these are the reforms that
need to happen to make sure we don't
have this dangerous behavior again and
then move on
isn't it their job joey the border
patrol uh to make sure that things at
the border go
smoothly and to not let there be chaos
at the border and i'm not even
addressing the issue of something
there's a man alive that spent 40
something years in the government that
has the calloused hands or the intellect
of the men on that horse
and that and that's what that's really
the heart of this problem is that
there's the american people and then
there's the elite class that get to
think they govern them i mean to think
you can stand there and accuse them of
the most egregious intent in the world
to be racist and trying to whip people
when they're trying to enforce a policy
that this administration ideologically
stands fundamentally against think about
this we have an entire agency of
government whose mandate is to enforce
the border and control the border and
they have people in the white house that
are fundamentally and ideologically
against that notion so what do they do
they use them as a scapegoat they
demonize them and then they look for any
little technicality they said that they
are going to punish them because they
use defensive language now don't you
think if that were a racial slur that's
exactly what they say they did so they
probably said something like get the
hell back yeah and because they yelled
at them and raised their voice there
were quotes in that report of what they
did and i believe richard fowler was on
today trying to say that uh the people
on horseback were wrong because we have
some standing um agreement or or policy
to let specifically the people of haiti
into this country we do
at a border checkpoint yeah so they can
get on a horse and push those people
towards a border checkpoint all day long
and that's what they were trying to do
and there's some places that only a
horse can go so when americans sit there
and watch that and they see those men
and or women on horseback they go wow
those are people willing to do anything
with calloused hands to protect this
country and they see a man in the white
house who can't get a sentence out of
his mouth accuse them of things and they
say yeah that person is unfit to be
president well not only is he unfit
katie i mean if he can see something
literally on a videotape make a judgment
a prejudicial judgment what the hell is
he doing on the world stage with leaders
who are playing him like a fiddle yeah
he's turning on the very agents whose
mission it is to protect the american
people to secure the border and to
protect the economic prosperity of the
united states of america that's the
mission of border patrol and this is a
perfect example of the problem of the
suits versus the boots they are
punishing and they've already punished
these guys because they took them off
the front line they sat them at a desk
they took the horse patrol unit off of
that part of the border making it easier
for the cartel and criminal elements to
operate and they were doing their job
they were trying to protect the american
people from illegal immigrants doesn't
matter where they're from they're
illegal immigrants coming across the
border illegally without permission and
we don't know who these people are they
don't have any vetting they have no
paperwork we don't know who they are
there's been tons of criminals who've
come across the border they just simply
did their job and so for joe biden to
get up and say immediately that they
were guilty that they would be punished
even and then today you have customs and
border protection come out and say there
is no evidence they did anything wrong
and yet they are still going to be
punished is the very definition of a
political witch hunt it's an abuse of
power and i hope these agents have some
kind of recourse at some point and for
secretary my orcis at the beginning who
said they weren't whipping anybody they
don't even have reins he defended them
initially until he got a phone call from
the white house to save president joe
biden's ego and his pride because he he
lied about what happened uh and
continued that narrative for the sake of
you know the people who are pushing it
it's despicable and disgusting and
exactly what's wrong with their border
policy in general you know greg when you
think about it the idea of going after
border patrol who they put at the border
on horses who they say protect the
american people and then they want to
punish them when we've got how many
pounds of fentanyl that are coming into
this country on any given day killing
americans left and right and they're
worried about this situation and they're
not even checking for the fentanyl
if you want a definition of a truly
dystopian universe
it's when the authority tells you that
you've done nothing wrong but you're
still getting punished i mean it's the
old line show me the person and i'll
show you the crime that's exactly what
this is you can't find it i mean this is
this would make kafka proud this is you
know
right up there with two plus two equals
five and orwell's 1984. it's like yeah
we found nothing wrong but you'll be
sentenced to five years of hard labor
right no it it it is that's the thing
that i think
should disgust everybody in terms of
offensive language the real offensive
language was comparing border patrol to
slave owners uh to calling calling all
of this they use this language this
dramatic language it's horrific it's
brutal they will pay
and it's like it's like that rash hyper
dramatic tweet you put out that gets all
the attention and then when it turns out
you're dead wrong the correction is just
a little mouse squeak and nobody or new
york times putting it on page b-35 so no
one finds it this story is important for
a lot of reasons it's part of the
pattern among the democrats and the
media not to care about an issue until
there's an american villain to amplify
so there's a lot of bad stuff going on
at the at the border you bring up
fentanyl there's lots of chaos
suffering coyotes rape but there's no
story without an american darth vader do
you know do you remember how
desperate we were on this show to get
people to cover the border and then all
of a sudden it was like the spigot got
turned with that the spigot that was
turned off got turned on and uh a full
force and then it was like around the
clock it was incredible and it was
another colluded uh enterprise of media
and and the democratic party to create a
hoax and this is why people have lost
trust in the media they've lost trust in
the government they they've seen the
fine people hoax the drinking bleach
hoax this hoaxers the russian collusion
oaks
they see the democrats and the media in
bed together they can't trust them and
then they they amplify this story and
then they bury others so what
we talked about the hunter biden stuff
being buried but let's not forget 50
plus migrants died
in a in a truck driven by a meth head
that story
got what a half an hour yeah
think about that biden cared more about
vilifying a single individual than the
55 or 56 people that died in that truck
and several thereafter right hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else